good morning believe uh-huh that's a
little high okay here we go
good morning believe nation today's
message is everything is a season over
to you
Myles Munroe change is inevitable change
is also the principle of life that means
everything that is alive will change and
even things that are not alive will
change you know a lady came to me she
says I came to the Bahamas for the last
10 years and I missed four years and I
came here this past month and everything
is different the airport is new she said
what happened to the old airport she
says in other words even the things not
alive are changing the way the river
runs down the mountain is wearing away
the mountain you go back to that
mountain ten years later and the river
is wider change is in creation it's part
of life so here is the question then
ecclesiastical 3 it says to everything
there is a season and to every purpose
under heaven there is a time for it to
everything there's a season how many
things have a season everything this is
one of the best news I ever got in my
life when I understood this I was a
teenager and it changed my life when I
understood that everything is a season
let me tell you why
if you having a bad time right now it
cannot last
if you cannot find a job right now that
is only a season if your business is
going in the wrong direction it's a
seasonal slide if nobody wants to marry
you that's only a season they're gonna
come a season everybody want to marry
you you got choices if you have no money
right now the good news is I am
seasonally broke they a neighbor
it's only for a time that's the good
news
that's why we are always reminded never
make a permanent decision in a temporary
problem all right so this is gonna be a
little bit unorthodox
obviously you don't see Evan here he
challenged me when I heard the message
everything is a season I felt like I
start understood already the message
before you watching the video so I might
either make a fool of myself because I
actually haven't seen the video that I'm
about to talk about or I'm gonna be
really spot-on what I think that yeah
that Myles Munroe is talking about is
that we often put off a change that we
want in our lives for next week next
season the new year you know sort of
like a resolution right okay you know
what in 2017 2018 we're gonna start
working out I'm gonna start doing this
but I think with the what Moz Monroe is
really talking about is every day can be
a new season a new inspiration and a new
form of change that you can do and it
speaks really true about being you're in
charge of your life and be you know the
author to your story right that if you
are not happy at work if you're not
happy with your friends if you're not
happy in your relationship whatever do
it now don't wait till next week don't
wait till you get a paycheck
don't wait till Christmas comes or
whatever it is do it now now is when you
need to change so the question of the
day is that I do a good job was I right
it was not even close to what the video
was talking about leave it
in the comments below thank you so much
for watching I have an amazing day I
believe in you and I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso I believe in you what's the
first thing I believe in you
I hope you can seem to be Lee even send
you where I didn't fold that paper
airplane right okay come on and I
believe in you I hope you continue to
boo okay